outre atlantique l'élection
présidentielle est très différente de la
nôtre puisque le président américain est
élu au suffrage universel indirect
qu'est ce que cela veut dire
concrètement et bien lors du vote
populaire le 3 novembre les électeurs
des 50 états ne voteront pas directement
pour donald trump ou joe biden mais pour
ceux qu'on appelle les grands électeurs
qui sont en quelque sorte les
représentants des candidats dans chaque
état ces grands électeurs sont en
général des officiels élus des
dirigeants du parti ou des personnalités
ayant une affiliation politique avec le
candidat en lice l'électeur lui n'a plus
qu'à choisir une fois élus ils forment
un collège électoral constitué de 538
grands électeurs qui se chargera d'élire
l'un des deux candidats
chaque état dispose d'un nombre fixé à
l'avance de grands électeurs en fonction
de la population qui réside par exemple
l'état le plus peuplé du pays la
californie possède 55 grands électeurs
l'alaska on a trois la pennsylvanie 20
et l'arizona en compte onze
dans la plupart des états c'est la règle
du winner takes all qui est appliquée
comprenez le gagnant prend tout cela
implique un état peut basculer d'un camp
à l'autre
prenez par exemple l'état du texas qui
comptabilise 38 grands électeurs si une
majorité des votants au ppte pour le
parti républicain
l'ensemble des grands électeurs de cet
état sera donc acquis par le candidat
républicain
ce système électoral peut faire
apparaître de grandes disparités entre
le nombre de suffrages remportés par un
candidat sur l'ensemble du territoire
américain et le nombre de grands
électeurs acquis
ainsi certains présidents des etats-unis
ont été les sans avoir obtenu le plus
grand nombre de voix dans le vote
populaire ce qui était le cas pour
donald trump en 2016 face à lui il y
avait hillary clinton qui avait ainsi
remporté près de 3 millions de votes de
plus sans pour autant gagner l'élection
présidentielle
c'est pour cette raison que les swing
states les états pivots connu pour
changer de camp maintiennent le suspense
et pourront peut-être faire basculer
l'issue du vote l'ohio est la floride ou
encore le michigan fait partie de ces
états qui peuvent changer de couleur
politique contrairement au tennessee qui
est un inconditionnel est un républicain
ou la californie
connu pour être profondément démocrates
une fois le vote populaire passé le 3
novembre
c'est aux grands électeurs de confiance
mais ce vote qui aura lieu le 14
décembre le 6 janvier c'est le décompte
officiel du vote des grands électeurs il
faut obtenir au minimum 2 170 votes pour
accéder à la maison blanche
l'investiture a lieu deux semaines après
le 20 janvier 2021